Oda goes from a developed or developing
countries,
it is vertical.
The developing country becomes a middle
income country,
so it graduates from being a recipient,
then another developing country.
What's to learn from it?
Success Story.
So they engage in south south
corporation,
efficient demand driven,
knowledge sharing and capacity building.
And look,
it's horizontal and it goes both ways.
Now this rent here wants to keep on
engaging with his former partner country
and to scale up together the lessons
learned into this new partner country.
So triangular cooperation is boring.
This is a win,
win,
win situation in which all countries in
both developed and developing share them
comparative advantages and work together
with one single thing in my very
policies for better lives.